Welcome back, everyone It's Charlie
the Marvels Movie just came out this week.
This will be my post-credits scene video
There is a whole bunch of stuff
they set up. A couple of different teams
that we'll see pretty soon in the MCU.
Couple of them people have been asking for for a while.
They're finally doing so. We'll break it all down.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
and careful for spoilers.
If you have not seen the movie yet,
But at the end of the movie, DA uses both of Mis
Marvel's Bangles, which they canonize
as the quantum bands of Quasar from the comics
to basically tear open a hole into another universe.
James Gunn
actually just introduced the second version of Quasar
from the comics in Guardians of the Galaxy three.
That's this character here.
there was even a deleted scene
that was meant to have taken place
at the beginning of the Marvel's movie to explain
how the original Quasar used the quantum bands
to create all the jump portals across the universe.
all the jump portals is wind up being a big plot point
during the movie Durban
basically tears open portals with the second bangle
that she found on another planet
to steal resources from different planets to rejuvenate
the dead.
Kree Homeworld HeLa, which they destroyed themselves
in a bitter civil war that erupted Andrew.
Captain Marvel killed the Kree Supreme Intelligence.
That was actually a deleted scene
from the first Captain Marvel movie,
basically leaving the Kree Homeworld
a barren wasteland.
So, Miss Marvel, Monica Rambeau,
Captain Marvel eventually do stop Da Ben from literally
joining Earth's sun at the end of the movie
to bring it back to the Kree Homeworld.
But she winds up getting the second bangle
using both of them both of the quantum Barnes
to tear open that hole to the other universe.
she winds up absorbing too much power
and it basically kills her.
then Ms..
Marvel and Captain Marvel energize
Monica Rambeau with their powers in both Bangles,
allowing her to absorb enough energy to become
powerful, enough to close the hole between universes.
But it strands Monica Rambeau in the other universe.
then what they did instead of having to post-credits
scenes are like two mid-credits scenes.
A lot of Marvel movies
will have multiple post-credits scenes.
They actually move one of the end credits
scenes to before the credits place,
which is part of the normal end of the movie.
this is what used to be the young Avengers
post-credits scene.
They just made it part of the actual film.
Kamala Khan bond
that Monica Rambeau is stuck in the other universe
and they don't have their little three way
Marvels team up anymore.
Likes the idea of being on a team so much
she even thought earlier in the movie
wrongly, that Nick Fury was testing her for a spot
on the regular new Avengers team.
So she swipes one of his data pads
that has all the files on superheroes all over Earth,
basically he's been keeping tabs
on all the powered individuals,
all the regular human superheroes
that don't have powers.
kind of the same way that Doctor Strange keeps
that list of all of Earth's
greatest threats
or the greatest threats to this dimension.
She decides to put together
a team of young superheroes, which will be the MCU
version of the Young Avengers, kind of combined
with the comic book version of the Champions.
if you haven't read any of those comics, Ms..
Marvel was on The Champions.
They're like one of the other teenage superhero teams.
She was never on the young Avengers.
she winds up working her way down
Nick Fury's list of other kids
that she wants to be on the team, basically people
who she thinks aren't going to be on the regular
new Avengers team, like all the B tier characters
she thinks are going to be available
her first stop is to go to New York City
and try and recruit Hailee Steinfeld.
Kate Bishop in the scene is meant to be
a parody of the Iron Man one post-credits
scene with Nick Fury showing up to recruit
Iron Man for the original Avengers
Most of
her speech is also meant to play out
like a parody of Nick Fury speech.
Like the dialog is the same or very similar.
here's the thing, though.
Nick Fury would have never told her that story.
So like in universe, it doesn't actually make sense
that she knew exactly what he said.
So the fact that she's saying the exact
same speech is Nick Fury back
in 2008 is more of like a real life Easter egg.
like the writers of the movie are just having fun
winking from behind the camera.
But like in universe,
there's no way that she would know
what he actually said to Iron Man during that meeting.
Notice. Kate Bishop is wearing her newer suit.
She's coming back from a night of super hearing.
Pizza Dogg also makes a cameo in the scene, too,
with another pizza reference.
she also jokes to Kamala Khan
that she's not a teenager.
Like I'm in my twenties.
What are you talking about? Teenage superhero team.
she's almost old enough to be a full avenger.
There was a lot of jokes about this in real life,
about Hailee Steinfeld becoming part of The Avengers.
People thought that she was too young when in reality
she's in her mid twenties and she's almost the age
to some of the original Avengers
actors were when they did the first Avengers movie.
She winds up begrudgingly agreeing to be on
Kamala Khan's team, even though she doesn't really
like the idea of being on a team quite so much,
which is very much like Kate Bishop from the comics.
She's kind of like that in the comics.
she kind of reluctantly joins
the young Avengers team in the original roster.
Ms.. Marvel then starts rattling off other superheroes
that she wants to be on the team
next In mentions
Ant-Man has a daughter, Cassie Lang she's referring to.
They actually reference Amy and the WASP Quantumania
during the Loki finale as well.
So there's like a lot more references
to recent Marvel movies.
basically the original comic book Young Avengers
team was Kate Bishop, Cassie Link Billion.
Tomi is Wiccan and Speed.
We'll actually see them come back into the MCU
in adult form.
Really?
Billy First he'll be played by Joe Locke during Agatha
Charcoal Diaries.
Then Tommy's coming back and like another spinoff
series, I believe Hulk Ling was on the original comic
book team, but I believe they'll swap him for Scar's
Son of Hulk, which they introduced during She-Hulk.
like they need a Hulk on the team,
and they already have a young Hulk.
Now, there was Patriot on that original team
who is Isaiah Bradley's grandson.
We actually met him during Falcon and Winter Soldier.
Maybe they'll bring him back
or maybe they won't do the character at all.
he might have gotten some biological powers
because of Isaiah Bradley passing along his abilities
through his super soldier serum, just biologically,
through his children and grandchildren.
there was Iron Lad on that original team
that was the young version of Kang.
They might substitute Riri Williams iron Heart for him.
We'll see about that.
She's also another character who's like a little bit
older, kind of like Kate Bishop.
Then there's America.
Chavez who will probably be on the team as well,
just because she's so young.
I'm not expecting them to put the younger
T'Challa Black Panther on the team.
I think they're saving him
and they'll just age him up when they do.
The Big Marvel reboot after Secret Wars in.
He'll just make a beeline straight
for the full Avengers
so that black Panther can be on The Avengers
in the future.
that means the young Avengers in the MCU will start off
with at least like six or seven characters.
And I think they want that to be similar
to the original young Avengers,
only being six characters
the baby, just slowly grow that team
the way that the original Avengers
grew in size over Avengers movies They didn't say.
When the team itself is going to debut it, it's going
to be before Avengers five or during Avengers five.
But at some point they'll do some spinoff projects
with the young Avengers just by themselves.
one of the very first stories that they actually
debuted in was a Kang the Conqueror storyline.
soon, very apropos that they're introducing
the young Avengers during this larger multiverse.
Kang The Conqueror Council of Kang's
storyline we're in the middle of right now.
Then we have the actual Mid-Credits scene.
This is probably the scene
that most people are going to be talking about
after the movie, the big X-Men scene.
So Monica Rambeau
wakes up in the hospital room of the X-Mansion
inside the other universe next to her mother Maria Rambeau.
who in this universe also became
a version of Captain Marvel instead of Carol Danvers.
But she's going by the binary name from the comics
and wearing the more modernized version
of binaries costume from the original comics couple
big deep cuts about the binary character as well.
Chris Claremont, famous X-Men writer,
created the character during an X-Men storyline.
she also became part of the X-Men team
in that storyline.
So for instance, this version of Binary in the MCU
is part of this X-Men team.
He revealed the reason why he changed Ms..
Marvel into binary during that issue is because Marvel
editorial wouldn't let him use the Phenix character
and he wanted to use the Phenix.
So binary was meant to be kind of
like the stand in for her.
but essentially she's like a more powered up
version of Ms..
Marvel.
Captain Marvel seemed like a way
more powerful version of the character
then because they're in the expansion,
like they're in the middle of an X-Men team,
we see that beast is treating them both, and it's
Kelsey Grammar back as the version of the character
the big difference this time though
is that it's completely motion capture.
He's not wearing a beast prosthetic suit
like he was during X-Men Last Stand
because it has been a hot miniseries.
That movie came out.
He's a bit of an older gentleman
now, a little bit easier for them to do
a big action scene with Beast as Kelsey Grammer
if they do it.
Motion capture
Monica Rambeau has no idea what's happened.
Like she doesn't know who the X-Men are,
so she thinks this is actually her mother, Maria Rambeau.
But in this universe, they explained that
Maria never got married, never had children.
So Monica doesn't exist in this universe.
She has no idea who this woman is.
she probably just thinks that it's weird
that she has her mother and father's eyes.
Like,
why do you look kind of like my mother? That's weird.
in the whole idea of it wasn't clear.
This isn't meant to be like the main X-Men universe
from the Fox movies.
It is meant to be a different universe
where a version of the X-Men exists,
like it's not the A38 universe or anything like that.
But it does mention Charles Professor
X wanting an update.
So Patrick Stewart
also back as another version of Professor X
For the most part this is meant to be a set up
for the events of Deadpool three where we'll see
a bunch of classic X-Men actors coming back
as different versions of their characters
from different universes. during
that movie, Deadpool supposed to search the multiverse
for like the perfect version of Wolverine.
It eventually comes to the realization that Hugh
Jackman's version is still the perfect Wolverine.
during the movie, they wind up facing a bunch
of other X-Men characters from other universes.
generally just meant to be a joke.
Just clowning on the fact that Kevin Foggy
is going to recast all the X-Men actors
when he does a big reboot
in the next big X-Men movie in the MCU.
I know there are a bunch of questions
about what's going on with Deadpool
hopping around the multiverse with Wolverine because of
everything that Loki did during the Loki finale.
But I don't want to get too much into that
in this video just because it just came out
so opposed to link for my Loki finale video
at the end of this.
generally I'm not expecting Monica Rambeau
to come back in Deadpool
three in some kind of cameo scene
or anything like that.
There might be some references to what happened here,
but I think the plot of that
movie will be completely different
in another different universe.
then there's kind of a hidden post-credits
scene over the very end of the credits.
So it's more of a funny moment.
Doesn't really have anything to do
with the actual plot of future movies.
It's meant to be a flick in making cat sounds,
just an audio form over the actual end credits.
And it's meant to be a reference to the Avengers
endgame and credits scenes
with the banging Iron Man
sounds over the credits from that first Iron Man movie.
one of the other notable changes
that you probably detected in the Post-Credits
scenes is the very end of the movie.
There's no kind of teaser message
about any of the characters returning, like
Captain Marvel, Miss Marvel, Monica Rambeau,
even though we know all three of them will be back.
Normally, at the end of Marvel movies, they say
Captain America will return or Thanos will return.
But at the end of this movie, there's none of that.
I know there's going to be a ton of questions
about X-Men and the MCU.
And this all gets into Deadpool three stuff.
They actually just announced that they're going to
start filming Deadpool three again before Thanksgiving.
Wolverine going to be carving that turkey left
and right, Ryan Reynolds also just announced that
they delayed the movie to July next year and debuted
a picture of dog paw, who is a character in the movie.
Like this is legit.
It's like a teaser for what
dog poop is going to look like during the film.
Who is a comic book character
Kevin Foggy was also teasing
that we would see more from the X-Men just in general.
Look, the concept X-Men based characters
in the next couple of years,
way, way more eventually
what's probably going to happen with the X-Men
is that he will recast a lot of the characters,
not till they do the next X-Men solo movie.
So a lot of the people that are coming back,
like the classic X-Men actors, or mostly
just for Deadpool three and for like Secret Wars,
which is a big multiverse movie.
They're kind of giving those characters like the Fox
Marvel actors, their own version of Avengers Endgame
before they recast a lot of people So for example,
that's the reason why we're probably going
to see the new version of the MCU X-Men movie,
maybe before Secret Wars and Wolverine
is not going to be in that movie because Hugh Jackman
will still be playing the character.
so like every single classic X-Men character
won't debut in that first new X-Men movie.
Like, they'll wait off a couple more years before
they show the brand new MCU version of Wolverine.
But if there's any other questions
or any of the Easter eggs
you spotted in the post-credits scenes that they didn't
talk about in the video, just write them below
in the comments, like, is it like the real big concepts
that they tease in the end credits the post-credits
the end of the movie, or the young Avengers team
and the X-Men characters in the other universes?
I'm still working on my full breakdown
and Easter eggs for the entire Marvel's movie
that should post on Saturday.
There's a bunch of other big stuff coming up too.
I've got a bunch of Loki bonus videos like alternate
endings, deleted scenes, Loki, Season three stuff.
make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
So click here for my full Loki finale video
and click here for that full Marvel's movie breakdown.
All of these a link as soon as I post that
to Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!